Like a lot of kids, he liked to play with fire. He'd snap off match heads from matches, pile them up and light them. He'd make little paper boats, float them in the toilet and set fire to them.
像许多孩子一样，他喜欢玩火。他会把火柴头掰下来，堆在一起点燃。他还会折小纸船，放在马桶里漂着，然后点火烧掉它们。
You know, I was fascinated by watching fire. It was silent. It was powerful. And I just liked the idea of things being consumed, you know? I liked to watch the paper turn brown and curl, and I liked to hear the crackle. I could watch it for hours, you know, nothing else in the world would matter.
你知道，我着迷于看火。它是安静的，充满力量。我只是喜欢那种东西被消耗掉的感觉，你知道吗？我喜欢看纸变焦、卷曲，我喜欢听那噼啪声。我可以盯着看好几个小时，你知道的，世界上其他任何事情都不重要了。
Later on, at a job when I was bored, we would play with lighters, and Binanca, and fill up cans with lighter gas and like cause a flame jet to shoot out one of the holes and stuff.
后来，在工作时觉得无聊，我们会玩打火机和比安卡，往罐子里灌打火机燃料，然后让火焰从其中一个孔喷出来之类的。
In her short story "Some Say the World," Susan Perabo has a character explain what's so thrilling to her about setting fires. "It's the moment when it may or may not go out of control," Susan Perabo writes. "The thing about fire is this-- it's yours for one glorious moment. You bear it, you raise it.
在短篇小说《有人说世界》中，苏珊·佩拉博让一个角色解释了她对放火感到如此刺激的原因。“那是火可能失控也可能不会失控的瞬间，”苏珊·佩拉博写道。“火的特别之处在于——在辉煌的一刻，它是属于你的。你孕育了它，你抚养了它。”
"The first time, in a record store downtown, I stood over the bathroom trashcan thinking I would not let it grow. That I would love it only to a point and then kill it. That's the trick with fire, for that 30 seconds you have a choice, spit on it, step on it, douse it with a can of Coke. But wait one moment too long, get caught up in its beauty, and it's grown beyond your control. And it is that moment that I live for, the relinquishing. The power passes from you to it. The world opens up and you with it. I cried in the record store when the flame rose above my head, not from fear, but from ecstasy."
“第一次，在市中心的一家唱片店里，我站在洗手间的垃圾桶上，心想我不会让它蔓延。我想我会适可而止，然后熄灭它。这就是玩火的诀窍，在那30秒里你有选择，可以吐口水在上面，踩灭它，或者用一罐可乐浇灭。但如果多等了一会儿，沉迷于它的美，它就会长到你无法控制的地步。我为那一刻而活，那种放手。力量从你身上转移到了它身上。世界向你敞开，你也随之敞开。当火焰升过我的头顶时，我在唱片店里哭了，不是因为恐惧，而是因为狂喜。”
Hello from WBEZ in Chicago. It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, stories of people who are not appropriately scared of fire. Act one, Firestarter, why one teenager set fires and then stopped setting them. Act two, Centralia, an inextinguishable subterranean fire on the edge of a small Pennsylvania town, and why the few remaining residents are not afraid of it.
芝加哥WBEZ电台向您问好，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目讲述的是那些对火不够敬畏的人的故事。第一幕，“纵火犯”，为什么一个少年会放火然后又停止了放火。第二幕，“森特勒利亚”，宾夕法尼亚州一个小镇边缘的一场无法扑灭的地下大火，以及为什么仅存的少数居民并不害怕它。
Act three, Firewalk. That act is about a guy who is not afraid of walking on burning coals, and how he might have been safer if he had simply taken the simple precaution of being afraid. Act four, The Big Picture on fire, the really, really, really big picture. Act five, The Fire Within. Stay with us.
第三幕，“火上行走”。这一幕关于一个不怕在燃烧的煤炭上行走的人，以及如果他采取了害怕这一简单的预防措施，他本可以更安全。第四幕，“关于火的宏观大局”，非常、非常、非常宏观的大局。第五幕，“心中的火”。请继续收听。
Act one, Firestarter. Our firestarter is 29, lives in New York City, and he moved from a casual interest in fire to arson, to actual criminality. And what's striking about his story is that he wasn't motivated by anger, or revenge, or any mean feelings toward anybody. He just wanted to stare at a fire the way a child does, and he didn't want to restrain himself, the way an adult does.
第一幕，“纵火犯”。我们的纵火犯今年29岁，住在纽约市，他从对火的随意兴趣转变为纵火，再到实际的犯罪行为。他的故事引人注目的是，他不是出于愤怒、报复或对任何人的恶意。他只是想像孩子一样盯着火看，而他不想像成年人那样克制自己。
The serious stuff came when I went to college. There was a house on campus that got hit by a truck, by a drunk driver, and the rumor was that the house was going to be scheduled for demolition. So my friends and I decided that, since it was scheduled for demolition, they were going to tear it down anyway, that there wouldn't be much harm in setting the house on fire. And we decided to start a fire in the house one night. We went there. We pried the boards off-- the house had been boarded up-- we pried the boards off, climbed in the window, and lit it on fire, and then climbed out the window and took off.
严重的事情发生在我上大学的时候。校园里有一栋房子被一辆卡车撞了，司机是个酒鬼，传言说那栋房子要被拆除。所以我和朋友们决定，既然它反正要被拆除，把它烧了也没什么大不了。我们决定在一个晚上在房子里放火。我们去了那里。我们撬开了木板——房子被木板封上了——我们撬开木板，从窗户爬进去，点火，然后爬出窗户逃走了。
I was giddy with excitement. My whole body was just like-- it was tingling. And we stayed away for a good hour or so to make sure we weren't caught at the scene of the crime, but I do remember coming back and seeing the fire trucks there.
我兴奋得头晕目眩。我的整个身体都在发麻。我们躲开了整整一个小时，确保没有在犯罪现场被抓到，但我确实记得回来时看到了消防车。
There was this sense of disappointment because the fire had been put out before the whole house had burned down. I think the fire never really got out of the bedroom. So there was definitely a disappointment, because the whole house hadn't burned down, and that was our goal.
有一种失望感，因为在整栋房子烧毁之前火就被扑灭了。我想火从来没有真正离开过卧室。所以确实很失望，因为整栋房子没有烧毁，而那正是我们的目标。
And if I could have done things the way I would have chosen to, we would have set the house on fire, and we would have sat up on a little hill at a safe distance watching it, drinking beers and watching it consume itself. Watch it slowly start to build, and then peak, and then watch the house fall down, and the fire eventually go out, and everything just turn to ashes. That would have been the way I wanted things to happen.
如果我能按自己的意愿去做，我们会点火，然后坐在不远处的小山上看着它，喝着啤酒，看着它自我消耗。看着它慢慢开始蔓延，然后达到顶峰，然后看着房子倒塌，火最终熄灭，一切化为灰烬。那才是我想要的。
In trying to find a pyromaniac to interview for today's program, one thing we discovered is that, first, it's actually very rare. A real mania, somebody with a real mania, psychological compulsion to set fires. Second, when it does occur, psychologists classify it as a sexual disorder, often as a sign of sexual abuse. That wasn't the case with this guy. He was mild compared to a real pyromaniac.
在寻找纵火狂进行采访时，我们发现的第一件事是，这其实非常罕见。真正的狂热，有真正心理强迫症的人放火。第二，当它发生时，心理学家将其归类为性障碍，通常是性虐待的迹象。但这个人不是这样。与真正的纵火狂相比，他很温和。
My interest in fire did stop fairly suddenly. A couple years ago, I think someone mentioned that I used to be a fire bug, and I realized that I wasn't fascinated by fire anymore. And I started wondering why that was, and I started thinking back and realizing that my fascination with fire ended right around the first time I got laid.
我对火的兴趣确实很突然地停止了。几年前，我想有人提到我以前是个玩火的人，我意识到我不再对火着迷了。我开始思考为什么，我开始回想，意识到我对火的迷恋在我第一次发生性关系前后就结束了。
And I was fascinated to find that, you know, that this was true. I was completely unaware of it at the time. It wasn't until like five or six years after it stopped that I looked back and realized that I had stopped playing with fire right around the time I started having sex. I think now I have a normal relationship with fire. I don't use fire to express myself anymore.
我惊讶地发现这是真的。当时我完全没有意识到。直到停止玩火五六年之后，我回过头来才意识到，我在开始性生活的时候就停止玩火了。我想现在我和火有一种正常的关系。我不再用火来表达自己了。
Act two, Centralia. This is the story of a town decimated by fire.
第二幕，“森特勒利亚”。这是一个被火摧毁的小镇的故事。
Oh, this was all built up along here. Our post office was right here at this corner, homes across the street, it was built up pretty solidly.
哦，这里曾经盖满了建筑。我们的邮局就在这个角落，街对面是住户，这里建得相当密集。
Lamar Mervine looks out the window of the municipal building at Locust and Centre Street, what used to be the middle of town.
拉马尔·默文望着市政大楼窗外，那里曾经是蝗虫街和中心街，也就是镇中心。
Right here, on this side of the home, was a big store.
就在这里，房子的这一边，曾经是一家大商店。
Grocery store?
杂货店？
General store, sold just about everything there. And the railroad used to run across here.
百货商店，几乎卖所有东西。铁路曾经穿过这里。
So describe this now.
那么现在描述一下这里。
Well, it's just mostly highways here now, a home here and there.
好吧，这里现在主要是公路，这里那里只有一两户人家。
Only one store now stands on Centre Street, vacant lots surround it. Perhaps two dozen homes are left out of the hundreds that used to be here. Centralia once had 3,000 people in it. Now there are 40. And the fire that decimated this town, that scattered its inhabitants far and wide, never touched a single home, never singed a building. This is a town destroyed by the idea of fire. And the fire itself never came.
中心街现在只剩下一家店了，周围都是空地。曾经的数百栋房子现在可能只剩下两打。森特勒利亚曾经有3000人。现在只有40人。那场摧毁了这个小镇、使其居民四散奔逃的大火，从未触及过任何一所房子，从未烧焦过任何一座建筑。这是一个被“火的观念”摧毁的小镇。而大火本身从未到来。
The fire that led to the evacuation of Centralia began out on the edge of town in an abandoned strip mine pit in 1962. There are 30 underground mine fires like this burning around Pennsylvania right now. They can burn slowly, for years. Most don't endanger anybody. But Centralia's built over old coal mines, and the fear was that the fire would jump from mine to mine and end up under the center of town.
导致森特勒利亚疏散的大火始于1962年镇边缘的一个废弃露天矿坑。宾夕法尼亚州目前有30个像这样的地下矿井火灾正在燃烧。它们可以慢慢燃烧多年。大多数不会危及任何人。但森特勒利亚是建立在旧煤矿上的，人们担心火会从一个矿坑跳到另一个矿坑，最终到达镇中心下方。
The coal is burning one small section at the end of our borough, and it has never gone anywhere else, never.
煤炭正在我们区尽头的一小部分燃烧，它从来没有去过别的地方，从来没有。
I met with five of the remaining residents of Centralia-- one eighth of the town-- in the town council's meeting room. John Comarnisky, a science teacher at a nearby high school, was quick to pull up various government charts and reports that prove, he says, that the subterranean fire is not a danger to the town.
我在镇议会的会议室里见到了森特勒利亚的五位常住居民——占全镇人口的八分之一。约翰·科马尼斯基，附近一所高中的科学老师，很快拿出各种政府图表和报告，他说这些证据证明地下火灾对小镇没有危险。
This is off the government's website, apparently. That's what they told us back when. And this is from the Department of Community and Economic Development. That's the boys who are basically empowering this whole thing, running the whole program.
这是从政府网站上拿下来的，显然是这样。这就是当时他们告诉我们的。这是来自社区和经济发展部。那些人基本上是在授权这件事，运营整个项目的人。
And you can see that basically you have the borough of Centralia here, and you have fire being spread in this direction, that direction, and all these other directions, southwest, and Centralia's the only place, the only direction it isn't going, and in fact, this federal study says that that's what should happen.
你可以看到，基本上这里是森特勒利亚区，火正在向这个方向、那个方向以及所有其他方向蔓延，西南方向，而森特勒利亚是唯一一个火没有去的地方，事实上，这份联邦研究报告说情况确实应该如此。
And because there's a mine pool underneath Centralia, right now, the coal underneath us is underwater. And there's no way that even the government will try and tell you that coal underwater burns, because it just doesn't.
而且因为森特勒利亚下面有矿井积水，现在我们下面的煤在水下。即使是政府也不会试图告诉你水下的煤会燃烧，因为根本不会。
I was involved in this from 1969 on.
我从1969年开始就参与其中了。
Helen Womer says the reason the government has tried to convince the people of Centralia that their town is in danger and evacuated the town is because Centralia sits on as much as $3.2 billion-- that's billion-- worth of coal.
海伦·沃默说，政府试图让森特勒利亚的人民相信小镇处于危险之中并疏散小镇，原因是因为森特勒利亚下面有高达32亿美元——是的，是十亿——的煤炭。
This is what this whole entire situation is about. It's about our coal. And I don't care who you talk to, I don't care what they say, they are not telling the truth. They could talk till they're blue in the face about how we should get out of here because we are in danger from gases, from subsidences, from all these horrible elements, and that isn't true at all. If we didn't have any coal beneath us, Centralia would be right where it is, the entire community.
这就是整个情况的本质。这关乎我们的煤。我不在乎你和谁谈，我不在乎他们说什么，他们说的不是实话。他们可以喋喋不休地说我们应该离开这里，因为我们受到气体、地陷、所有这些可怕因素的威胁，而那根本不是真的。如果我们下面没有煤，森特勒利亚整个社区仍会留在原处。
They don't have a lot of hard evidence to prove this government conspiracy. No paper trail, no witnesses, no names they're willing to name on the record. But what they do seem to be entirely correct about is this-- in 35 years, the fire has not moved from the edge of town toward the center, and has not injured anyone.
他们没有多少确凿的证据来证明这种政府阴谋。没有纸质记录，没有证人，没有他们愿意实名公开的名字。但他们似乎完全正确的一点是——35年来，火从未从镇边缘移向中心，也从未伤害过任何人。
What seems to have happened in Centralia is this-- the fire burned for 19 years, and then in 1981 came one of those turning point, made for TV events that can take your average, ongoing, unextinguished subterranean fire, and turn it into a state-wide media circus.
森特勒利亚发生的事情似乎是这样的——大火燃烧了19年，然后在1981年，发生了一场电视报道式的转折点事件，它把一场普通的、持续不断的、未扑灭的地下火灾变成了一场全州范围的媒体马戏团。
On February 14th, 1981, Todd Domboski was walking across his backyard when the ground beneath him suddenly gave way, and he was knee deep in steaming mud.
1981年2月14日，托德·多姆博斯基正走在后院，地表突然塌陷，他膝盖以下陷入了冒着蒸汽的泥浆中。
This is a video made by the state to brief its own policy makers on the history of the fire.
这是州政府为向其政策制定者简要介绍火灾历史而制作的一段视频。
Fortunately, a friend heard his cries for help and managed to reach into the hole and drag him out by the collar of his coat. Government officials, who were visiting Centralia that day, were summoned to the scene. Someone in their party dropped a large block into the hole, and no one heard it hit bottom.
幸运的是，一个朋友听到了他的呼救声，设法伸手进洞里，抓着他的衣领把他拉了出来。那天正在访问森特勒利亚的政府官员被召集到现场。他们队伍中的某个人向洞里扔了一块大石头，没有人听到它到底部。
Before the story hit the TV news, the big political fight in Centralia was townspeople trying to get the government to block the fire or put it out. After the story hit the TV news, the government declared there was no way to tell where the fire might go next. They decided to evacuate. Bill Clank, who headed the location effort, says it was the only reasonable decision. Twice the state tried to erect barriers to block the fire, he says, and twice it jumped the barriers.
在故事登上电视新闻之前，森特勒利亚的主要政治斗争是市民试图让政府封锁火源或将其扑灭。在故事登上电视新闻后，政府宣布无法判断火势下一步会蔓延到哪里。他们决定撤离。负责安置工作的比尔·克兰克说，这是唯一合理的决定。他说，州政府曾两次尝试建立障碍物来阻挡火势，但两次都跳过了障碍物。
They trenched and inserted fly ash. It's supposed to be an uncombustible material. And this was to keep the fire from crossing the road that is now closed off up at the top of the hill by the Catholic church. Well, the fire did it, it went through there, and it was on the other side of the road. And then they put a clay barrier on top of that and tried to keep-- because there were fumes.
他们开挖并填入了粉煤灰。这应该是一种不可燃材料。这是为了防止火势穿过现在天主教堂山顶上方封闭的道路。好吧，火势做到了，它穿过了那里，到了道路的另一边。然后他们在上面又加了一层粘土障碍物试图阻挡——因为有烟雾。
And I honestly believe that when a fire gets to the magnitude that it is now, that it's like a hurricane or anything else. You don't tell the fire what it's going to do. It does what it damn well pleases.
我真诚地相信，当火灾达到现在的规模时，它就像飓风或其他任何事情一样。你不能命令火怎么做。它随心所欲。
The government calculated that it would cost $42 million to buy everyone's home. The request was put into the federal government. Once people heard about the potential money, says Helen Womer, the town split. Lots of people were living in these old houses built by the coal companies decades before.
政府计算出收购每个人房子的费用需要4200万美元。请求已提交给联邦政府。海伦·沃默说，一旦人们听说有钱，小镇就分裂了。很多人住在这里的煤炭公司几十年前建造的老房子里。
Very, very few people moved out of this town because of the fire. I want to make that perfectly clear. The government came in with big bucks. A lot of the homes, their children had all left, they were raised. They were left with these white elephant big houses, a lot of them needed fixing, so they knew that where to make the most money was to sell your home to the government.
极少数人因为火灾搬出了这个镇。我想把这一点说清楚。政府带着大笔钱进来了。很多房子，他们的孩子都离开了，已经长大成人。他们留下了这些白象般的大房子，很多需要修理，所以他们知道赚钱最多的地方就是把房子卖给政府。
Two community organizations faced off. One, to keep people in Centralia and the fire out; the other to sell out and get out. People in the other camp knew where Helen Womer stood. They would blow smoke in her face in public, throw their pass books at her when she worked her bank teller job. Somebody lit an M-80 firecracker on her lawn. Somebody else threw a cat at her.
两个社区组织对峙起来。一个是为了留住森特勒利亚的人民并把火挡在外面；另一个则是为了变卖资产并离开。对方阵营的人知道海伦·沃默的立场。他们在公共场合对着她的脸吐烟，在她做银行柜员工作时把存折扔向她。有人在她草坪上点燃了M-80鞭炮。还有人向她扔猫。
I know one thing. There are people that moved out of this town that can't wait till we're all out, because then, and only then, will they have peace of mind. Because as long as there is someone left in Centralia as adamant and committed as we are here in this town, they will never have peace of mind on what they did. Because many, many of them knew that they were instrumental in having Centralia in the condition that we are now.
我知道一件事。有些人搬出这个镇，他们迫不及待地等着我们全走光，因为那样，也只有那样，他们才能心安理得。因为只要还有一个人留在森特勒利亚，像我们一样坚定和执着，他们就永远不会对自己所做的事感到心安。因为他们中的许多人知道，他们参与了使森特勒利亚陷入如今这种境地的过程。
They would stop talking to you. They would stop being friendly. And that moment, the very moment that occurred, you knew that they were going to be next. That was the main thing, they would just stop being friendly, they would stop being neighborly. And that was your first indication that they had turned the other way.
他们会停止跟你说话。他们会不再友好。那一刻，就在那一刻，你知道他们将是下一个。那是主要的事情，他们只是不再友好，不再邻里互助。那是他们已经变了心的第一个迹象。
It was the other way around, the people that had moved, the people that stayed there were mad at them. Oh yeah, there were a lot of people mad.
情况恰恰相反，搬走的人，留在那里的人对他们很生气。哦，是的，很多人都很生气。
Did that happen to you?
你也遇到过这种情况吗？
Sure, a lot of them were mad at me.
当然，他们中很多人对我都很生气。
If you talk to former Centralia residents like Jerry Wasachanski, leaving town wasn't a grand betrayal, not at all. He says he had a heart attack, wanted to move into a house where he wouldn't have to shovel coal down in the basement into the furnace.
如果你和像杰里·瓦萨坎斯基这样的前森特勒利亚居民交谈，离开小镇并不是什么重大的背叛，根本不是。他说他患了心脏病，想搬进一栋房子，不用在地下室铲煤进炉子。
He and several other former residents did confirm what Helen Womer told me, though, that he was never scared of the underground fire reaching his house, never scared of underground gases seeping up and killing him. Mostly, he says, he moved because of the great deal the government gave him for his old house.
他和几位其他前居民确实证实了海伦·沃默告诉我的话，尽管如此，他从来没有害怕地下火会烧到他家，从来没有害怕地下气体渗上来毒死他。他说，他搬家主要是因为政府给他那栋老房子的条件太优厚了。
I moved in, it was $3,000, but then when I moved out of there, they gave us $55,000.
我搬进去时花了3000美元，但当我搬出来时，他们给了我55000美元。
$55,000 on a $3,000 investment-- a 2,000% profit. Now Jerry lives with his son Rob, about a 10 minute drive from Centralia, in Mount Carmel, where lots of former Centralians live. Rob says they held out a long time before they moved, that Centralia changed.
3000美元的投资换来55000美元——2000%的利润。现在杰里和他的儿子罗布住在离森特勒利亚约10分钟车程的卡梅尔山，很多前森特勒利亚人都住在那里。罗布说，他们在搬家前坚持了很长时间，森特勒利亚变了。
We were being bombarded with 110 feelings at one time. It was just getting to be too much. The town wasn't like it was. And if it would have stayed that way, we probably would have stayed up there. But when more and more people were going, it was just time to go.
我们同时受到了110种情绪的轰炸。那实在太多了。小镇不像以前那样了。如果还是老样子，我们可能会留在那儿。但当越来越多的人离开时，就是离开的时候了。
As with most government operations on the scale of this evacuation, there are really two ways that people look at what happened in Centralia. As a conspiracy, the way the remaining townspeople see it, or as simple human incompetence, the way Jerry's son Rob sees it.
对于大多数这种规模的政府疏散行动，人们看待森特勒利亚发生的事情通常有两种方式。一种是作为阴谋，这是剩下的镇民的看法；另一种是作为简单的人类无能，这是杰里的儿子罗布的看法。
What would the government do now? They spent all that money, they're not going to say they were wrong. They're not going to admit a mistake.
政府现在会做什么？他们花了那么多钱，他们不会说自己错了。他们不会承认错误。
But all the guys who would have made the mistake, they're already probably gone now anyways. It was 20 years ago.
但所有可能犯错的人现在大概都已经走了。那是20年前的事了。
Yeah, but federal government's federal government. They're not going to admit to it 20 years ago, or 20 years down the line they won't admit that they made a mistake.
是的，但联邦政府就是联邦政府。他们不会承认20年前的错误，或者在20年后他们也不会承认他们犯了错误。
They can't just say, fire moved, thought it was going to go this way, it went this way.
他们不能只说，火蔓延了，以为会往这边走，结果往那边走了。
When there's $42 million involved, I guess. I mean, they'd spend a lot more money on different crazy things, but, you aren't going to see them offer the land back, or even just sell it and make money, or start the town over.
我想当涉及到4200万美元时是这样。我的意思是，他们会在各种疯狂的事情上花费更多的钱，但是，你不会看到他们提供退还土地，甚至只是卖掉赚钱，或者让小镇重新开始。
Actually, there's a third way to view what happened in Centralia, the way that Bill Clank, head of the relocation effort, sees it, which is as a government program that actually worked. A rare example of government competence and generosity.
实际上，看待森特勒利亚发生的事情还有第三种方式，就是搬迁负责人比尔·克兰克的看法，即这是一个实际上奏效的政府项目。这是一个政府能力和慷慨的罕见例子。
Don't get me wrong, I agree with the people over there, that for a long time the government did not respond to this thing the way they should have, and that's why it's gotten to the point that it is. But when the government finally came through for them and said, look, we're going to give you a chance to get out of here, and not only that, we're going to give you a chance to build a new house, and make yourselves whole. We're not just going to give you the, maybe, if you're lucky, the $10,000 your property's worth, so that you can actually go out and afford to build a new home on the market, that's pretty hard to pass up for most people.
别误解我，我同意那边人们的观点，长期以来政府没有按照他们应该采取的方式应对这件事，这就是为什么情况会发展到今天这一步。但当政府最终为他们提供支持并说，看，我们要给你一个离开这里的机会，不仅如此，我们要给你一个建造新房子的机会，让你生活恢复完整。我们不只是给你可能，如果你幸运的话，你的房产价值10000美元，这样你实际上可以在市场上负担得起建一个新家，这对大多数人来说是很难拒绝的。
In  1992, after a decade of voluntary relocation of the people from Centralia, the state condemned the remaining homes there, told everyone they had to get out, declared eminent domain. The mayor and town council back then took this to court. They appealed it all the way up to the US Supreme Court. They did not win one case.
1992年，在森特勒利亚人民自愿搬迁十年后，州政府征收了那里剩下的房子，告诉每个人他们必须离开，宣布了征用权。当时的镇长和镇议会将其告上法庭。他们一直上诉到美国最高法院。他们没有赢得任何一个案件。
Then the town council back then resigned, left town, saying it was over. They'd lost. Legally, no one has the right to stay in Centralia anymore. For the 40 diehards who still live there, like Helen Womer, these final departures were the bitterest betrayal.
然后当时的镇议会辞职了，离开了小镇，说一切都结束了。他们输了。在法律上，没有人再有权留在森特勒利亚。对于像海伦·沃默这样仍然住在那里40名死硬分子来说，这些最后的离开是最苦涩的背叛。
I had a neighbor who we fought shoulder to shoulder for years and years. And then she got involved with-- I mean, she turned. But not only that, it's not only she turned, she stopped talking. She turned into a different person, absolutely different person.
我有一个邻居，我们肩并肩战斗了很多年。然后她参与了——我的意思是，她变了。不仅如此，不仅仅是她变了，她还停止了交流。她变成了一个不同的人，完全不同的人。
And does she live nearby still?
她现在还住在附近吗？
She lives in-- about four miles, I guess.
她住在——我想大约四英里外。
So very close?
所以非常近？
Very, very close.
非常，非常近。
But you're not social anymore?
但你们不再往来了？
Well, I mean that was her decision. No, we're not social. I mean, we were neighbors, and we got along wonderfully, wonderfully together. That was sad.
嗯，那是她的决定。不，我们不往来。我的意思是，我们曾经是邻居，而且我们相处得非常、非常融洽。那很令人难过。
Now in the long stretch of grass that used to be the middle of town, someone put in some benches and a sign that says, we love Centralia. Jerry Wasaschinski and the other old men who left town because of the idea of a fire travel from their homes elsewhere, come back to Centralia, not for the town that it is, but for the idea of the town it was.
现在，在曾经是镇中心的那片长草地上，有人放了一些长椅和一个写着“我们爱森特勒利亚”的牌子。杰里·瓦萨坎斯基和其他因为火的观念而离开小镇的老人们，从他们现在住的地方回到森特勒利亚，不是为了现在的这个小镇，而是为了那个曾经存在的小镇的观念。
Now I go up there, about seven, eight guys go up there at night time when the weather's nice. And we might have a little hot dogs, or a bottle of beer or something, something like that. And then we talk about the old town. But now they're fading away. Two of them died already, and their homes are being torn down. One lad is paralyzed now, and the other one, he can't drive anymore. So it's fading away up there, too.
现在我过去那儿，天气好的时候，晚上大约七八个人会过去。我们可能会吃点热狗，或者喝瓶啤酒之类的。然后我们聊聊老镇。但现在他们正在消失。其中两个人已经去世了，他们的房子正在被拆除。一个人现在瘫痪了，另一个再也不能开车了。所以那里也在消失。
Act three, Fearless. This is the story about somebody who wasn't scared of fire and who did get burned because of it. Ki Kim studied Buddhism, meditated, avoided red meat. When a friend sent him an email inviting him on a firewalk retreat, he thought, why not? He'd been feeling sort of low.
第三幕，“无畏”。这是一个关于某人不怕火，却因此被烧伤的故事。基·金研究佛教，冥想，不吃红肉。当一个朋友发邮件邀请他参加一个火上行走静修会时，他想，为什么不呢？他一直觉得情绪有点低落。
The idea of the retreat is that you go, meditate, and at the culmination of the weekend, walk across hot coals. To make a long story short, he ended up with near third degree burns that made it difficult to walk for weeks. He spoke with This American Life producer Nancy Updike.
静修会的想法是，你去冥想，在周末结束时，走过热煤。长话短说，他最终受到了接近三度的烧伤，导致几周内行走困难。他接受了《美国生活》制片人南希·厄普代克的采访。
Ki had read a lot about firewalks. He knew they were a common ritual practiced around the world, and the story was always the same, no one gets burned, never happens. The one person he knew who had gone on a firewalk didn't get burned. The leaders of the retreat were so confident no one would get burned, they didn't even bother to bring first aid supplies.
基读过很多关于火上行走的书。他知道这是一种在世界各地广泛练习的仪式，故事总是相同的，没有人会被烧伤，从来不会发生。他认识的唯一一个参加过火上行走的人也没有被烧伤。静修会的领导者们非常自信，没有人会被烧伤，他们甚至懒得带急救用品。
The way the weekend started was we participated in a whole bunch of exercises that were designed to, you know, peel off these layers of personas that we build up and show to the world to protect our deepest selves.
周末开始的方式是我们参加了一大堆练习，旨在，你知道，剥离我们为了保护内心最深处而建立并展示给世界看的这些层面的人格。
How do you peel those layers off? We're all dying to know.
你怎么剥离那些层面？我们都迫不及待想知道。
Well, you know, one exercise had the people there pair off into groups, and one person would simply stare into the other's eyes while the person who is being stared at would have to answer questions like, who are you? And the whole idea was to gather together this group of strangers to share with each other their most intimate selves.
嗯，你知道，其中一个练习让在场的人分成小组，一个人只是盯着另一个人的眼睛，而被盯着的人必须回答诸如“你是谁？”之类的问题。整个想法是将这群陌生人聚集在一起，分享他们最私密的一面。
Why are you laughing?
你为什么在笑？
I don't know--
我不知道——
You participated.
你参与了。
Well, I guess I ought to warn you that much of what I have to say could very well be replete with New Agey jargon, which I think is kind of funny, but I do believe in a lot of this stuff.
好吧，我想我应该提醒你，我要说的很多话可能很可能充斥着新时代的术语，我觉得这有点好笑，但我确实相信其中的很多东西。
After the sun went down on that Saturday, we all formed a human chain with one part of the chain, or one person, standing at the pile of wood, and the other person at the point where the fire was going to be built. And so every single log that went into building this fire passed along this human chain. And, we surrounded the fire in this circle, and--
周六太阳落山后，我们所有人组成了一个人链，一部分人，或一个人，站在木堆旁，另一个人站在火堆要被建造的地方。所以每一根用于建造这堆火的木头都通过了这条人链。然后，我们在圆圈里围住火，然后——
And is it hot on your face?
这对你的脸来说热吗？
It was unbelievably hot. We were standing a good four or five feet away from it, and you could still feel the heat.
热得难以置信。我们离它有四五英尺远，你仍然能感觉到热量。
And still, at the point where it's on your face, and it's so hot, and it's this huge bonfire, and you're looking at this orange--
即便如此，在热气扑面而来的时候，而且它是一个巨大的篝火，你看着这橙色的——
Inferno.
炼狱。
Inferno, thank you, you're still not scared, you're feeling-- what are you feeling?
炼狱，谢谢，你还是不害怕，你感觉——你在感觉什么？
There isn't any fear, nor was there any concern. There was this kind of dull sense of contentment and peace.
没有任何恐惧，也没有任何担忧。有一种迟钝的满足感和宁静。
Sure. The dull contentment and peace that precedes a third degree burn.
当然。在三度烧伤之前的迟钝满足和宁静。
Right.
对。
So one explanation for why people don't get burned on firewalks is that they're so nervous they sweat, and that layer of moisture protects their feet. In other words, Ki got burned because he was too certain that he wouldn't be. If he'd been more scared of fire, if he'd been nervous and sweated, he probably wouldn't have gotten hurt.
所以，人们在火上行走时不会被烧伤的一个解释是，他们太紧张以至于出汗，那层水分保护了他们的脚。换句话说，基被烧伤是因为他太确定自己不会被烧伤。如果他更怕火，如果他紧张并出了汗，他可能就不会受伤了。
I had this conviction that I wouldn't get hurt. I can't really think of an explanation for why I had this, but I just simply didn't believe that it could hurt me. I mean, the moment that I stepped on the coals, I knew I was in trouble. And I could just feel my flesh sizzling.
我当时确信我不会受伤。我真的想不出为什么我有这种想法的解释，但我就是不相信它能伤害我。我的意思是，当我踏上煤炭的那一刻，我就知道我有麻烦了。我能感觉到我的肉在滋滋作响。
Oh my god.
哦，天哪。
And I don't know what it was in me that compelled me to keep walking, but I made it across, and collapsed into one of the co-leader's arms.
我不知道我体内有什么力量驱使我继续走，但我走过了，并瘫倒在其中一位联合领导人的怀里。
I was in a state of panic, and I was at a point where I felt like all my entire belief system had just collapsed from under itself. So I'm sitting off to the side, and the other people are also taking their turns going across the fire.
我处于恐慌状态，我感觉我整个信仰体系都崩溃了。所以我坐在旁边，其他人也轮流走过火堆。
And are you saying anything? Do they know that you've been burned?
你在说什么吗？他们知道你被烧伤了吗？
Actually, the way that I'd composed myself, everyone thought, oh yeah, Ki just made it across, no problem. I didn't say or do anything to suggest to the others that I was in a great deal of pain.
事实上，以我表现出来的镇定，每个人都以为，哦，是的，基只是走过去了，没问题。我没有说什么或做什么来让别人知道我正处于极度的痛苦之中。
Wow. You're perpetuating the racist cliche about your people, that you are inscrutable. You didn't say anything?
哇。你正在延续关于你们种族的种族主义陈词滥调，即你们是高深莫测的。你什么都没说？
Nobody had a clue. Earlier in that day, on these three by five index cards, we wrote down our three greatest fears. And we each took turns, one at a time, going up to the fire and tossed the index card into the fire.
没人知道。那天早些时候，在这些3x5的索引卡上，我们写下了我们最大的三个恐惧。我们每个人轮流走上前去，把索引卡扔进火里。
What were those fears?
那些恐惧是什么？
I guess the simplest way to put it was a fear of speaking.
我想最简单的说法是对说话的恐惧。
And that was what you put on the card?
那就是你写在卡片上的东西？
Ki finally did tell everyone how badly burned he was. He forced himself to speak. And he looks back on that moment when he had to overcome exactly the fear he had named as a moment of revelation. Because he got burned on his firewalk, he had to speak.
基最终确实告诉了大家他烧伤得有多严重。他强迫自己说话。当他回顾那一刻时，他不得不克服他所命名的那种恐惧，那一刻成了启示。因为他在火上行走时被烧伤了，他必须说话。
I feel like I got burned because getting burned was the appropriate experience for me to have at that point. Had I made it across unscathed, it would have made me think, oh yeah, I'm fine. Everything's cool. I'm on the path. Yeah, I'm getting there. Yeah, I think that if I didn't get burned, I can easily imagine that, if this makes any sense, I would have become less mindful in the way that I live.
我觉得我被烧伤了，因为在那个时候被烧伤是我应该有的经历。如果我毫发无损地走过去，那会让我觉得，哦，是的，我很好。一切都很酷。我在道路上。是的，我快到了。是的，我觉得如果我没有被烧伤，我很容易想象，如果这有什么道理的话，我会在生活中变得不那么正念。
Man, oh man, oh man. Well, coming up we step back for the big picture on humans and fire-- the really big picture. That's in a minute, when our program continues.
天哪，天哪，天哪。好吧，接下来我们要退一步，从宏观上看看人类与火的关系——真正宏观的角度。一分钟后，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to contribute various kinds of stories on the theme. Today's show, people who are not afraid of fire.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者贡献不同类型的主题故事。今天的节目，那些不怕火的人。
We've arrived at act four, as promised, The Big Picture. Stephen Pyne, a professor, believes that we Americans as a people, as a group, are too afraid of fire. And he says that this has all sorts of practical consequences. For example, in Yellowstone National Park, Pyne says the Forest Service policy of suppressing fires for the last 100 years out of fear of fire has led to an incredible overgrowth of flammable material, which caused the fires in 1988 that destroyed half the park. In other words, by trying to avoid fires, we called them down upon us.
我们正如约到达了第四幕，“宏观大局”。教授斯蒂芬·派恩认为，作为一个人群，作为一个群体，我们美国人太怕火了。他说这在实践中会导致各种后果。例如，在黄石国家公园，派恩说，森林管理局过去100年因害怕火而采取的扑火政策，导致了易燃物质的惊人过剩，这导致了1988年的火灾，摧毁了半个公园。换句话说，通过试图避开火灾，我们反而招致了火灾。
Pyne says that what humans have done throughout history is set fires in a controlled way, and that part of our problem today is the way that we think about fire, that we do not see it as a practical tool, that we're afraid of it.
派恩说，人类历史上所做的是以受控的方式放火，而我们今天面临的问题的一部分是我们看待火的方式，我们不把它看作一种实用的工具，我们怕它。
That's a very recent and, in some ways, a bizarre perception. There are good reasons to be afraid of fire. It's dangerous. It can be unpredictable. But people have always paired that perception of fire with the sense that it was necessary, essential, that it's what made the world habitable.
那是一个非常近期且在某些方面很怪异的观念。害怕火有正当理由。它很危险。它可能不可预测。但人们总是把对火的这种认知与一种感觉结合在一起，即它是有必要的、本质的，是它让世界变得适宜居住。
I mean, if you think about fire origin myths, and all cultures have them, almost always the story goes that humans are sort of a less capable or less well endowed species, then, through various means, usually by guile or theft, humans get it, or are given it, and then become powerful. Then, in a sense, they become human, and the essential features of who we are become apparent.
我的意思是，如果你思考火的起源神话，所有文化都有它们，几乎总是故事说人类是一个能力较弱或天赋较差的物种，然后，通过各种手段，通常是靠诡计或窃取，人类得到了它，或者被赋予了它，然后变得强大。然后，在某种意义上，他们变成了人类，我们本质特征变得显而易见。
I mean, in many ways, we really are the keepers of the planetary flame. And the sense that somehow, if we could abolish fire, it would be in our interest or the earth's interest, is a very peculiar and very modern, and urban, one.
我的意思是，在很多方面，我们真的是行星火焰的守护者。而认为如果我们能消灭火，对我们或地球有好处，这是一种非常独特、非常现代且城市化的观念。
Let me ask you, when you talk about societies where fire is valued, what societies are you thinking of? Are we talking about most agricultural societies?
让我问你，当你谈论重视火的社会时，你在想哪些社会？我们在谈论大多数农业社会吗？
Well, we're talking about almost every society other than, basically, an urban and industrial one. And industrial societies have sort of sublimated fire into machines, and we're not burning living biomass so much as fossil fuels, fossil biomass.
嗯，我们在谈论几乎除城市和工业社会之外的每一个社会。而工业社会已经将火升华到了机器中，我们燃烧的不是活的生物质，而是化石燃料，化石生物质。
In other words, we've gone from actually having real bonfires to these tiny little combustions inside engines?
换句话说，我们已经从真正拥有篝火转变成了发动机内部这些微小的燃烧？
That's right. And we have, essentially, particularly in cities, people's contact with fire is almost always negative. A city is not a nice habitat for fire. It occurs in wild forms, it's dangerous.
没错。而且我们基本上，特别是在城市里，人们接触火几乎总是负面的。城市不是火的好栖息地。它以野性形式出现，很危险。
So people used to grow up-- if you were in a rural setting, you grew up burning off debris in the spring, burning off your fallow fields, burning off the pastures to get rid of the old grass and start the new, all kinds of little sort of spring cleaning fires, if you will, and fires for other purposes.
所以人们过去经常长大——如果你在农村环境中，你在春天清理碎片，烧掉休耕地，烧掉牧场以清除旧草并开始长新草，各种小型的春季大扫除式的火，如果你愿意的话，以及用于其他目的的火。
But it seems to me all that kind of personal contact with fire is gone, and what we have largely left is a kind of imagery, a kind of virtual fire-- fires as presented for their telegenic effect, or fires used to dramatize other phenomenon. And in almost every case, the fire is negative.
但我觉得所有那种与火的个人接触都消失了，我们剩下的主要是某种意象，某种虚拟的火——为电视效果而展示的火，或者用于戏剧化其他现象的火。而且在几乎每一个案例中，火都是负面的。
Actually, as you describe this, I realized all of the movies, and all of the previews for movies I've seen lately, where fire is a huge element in those movies. There's a whole sequence of movies out now where volcanoes set cities on fire. I was at one of the Star Wars movies, and one of the things that struck me was just how much of the movie was simply about blowing things up.
实际上，当你描述这一点时，我意识到我看过的所有电影，以及最近看过的所有预告片，火在那些电影中都是一个巨大的元素。现在有一整系列电影，火山让城市着火。我在看一部《星球大战》电影时，让我印象深刻的一点是，电影的很大一部分仅仅是关于炸毁东西。
Blowing things up, and, at least, there is a more benevolent and ancient image in the last of it, where you have the funeral pyre for Darth Vader. But in general, you're right. Almost anything you can think of now, fire is used to sort of give visual and dramatic power to the story.
炸毁东西，而且，至少在最后有一幅更仁慈和古老的画面，那就是达斯·维达的葬礼火堆。但总的来说，你是对的。几乎你现在能想到的任何事情，火都被用来给故事一种视觉和戏剧性的力量。
But are you arguing, in some way, that we have this visual fetish for fire because fire is not a part of our everyday lives anymore?
但你是在某种程度上争辩说，我们对火有这种视觉上的迷恋，因为火不再是我们日常生活的一部分了吗？
I think we're allowing that to remain unchallenged, because in our personal sense, we don't have a sense of fire as a good force, fire as a useful tool, fire as something that makes the world habitable.
我认为我们允许这种观点未受挑战，因为在我们的个人感觉中，我们没有将火视为一种好的力量、有用的工具、让世界适宜居住的东西。
Well, what kind of iconography do you want to see?
好吧，你希望看到什么样的肖像？
Well, I would just like to see hearth fires. I would like to see some agricultural fires. I would like to see the Forest Service pair Smokey Bear with a complementary figure-- Smokey's twin brother, separated at birth or something, and he's there with a drip torch, and now they're together again, arm in arm, a paired set. That's the way it should be.
嗯，我只想看到炉火。我想看到一些农业用火。我想看到森林管理局给斯莫基熊找一个互补的人物——斯莫基的双胞胎兄弟，出生时失散什么的，他和滴火炬在一起，现在他们又在一起了，手拉手，一对组合。那样才是应该的。
And children would sometimes follow the example of Smokey the one who sets the fires, the other Smokey?
孩子们有时会跟随斯莫基的榜样，那个放火的斯莫基？
Right.
对。
I don't know if a lot of parents are going to go with you on that one.
我不知道有很多父母会支持你。
Well, it's not designed for urban environments, but I would like to have it in our consciousness that such things are possible.
好吧，它不是为城市环境设计的，但我希望我们的意识中知道这种可能性。
Are you arguing in some way we need to get back to fire? We need to embrace fire more than we are?
你是在某种程度上争辩说我们需要回归到火吗？我们需要比现在更多地拥抱火吗？
Well, I would like to see us first intellectually embrace it, and recognize that it is really part of our heritage as a species. We have a species monopoly over it. And to sort of renounce that seems to me very strange.
嗯，我希望我们首先在知识上拥抱它，并承认它确实是我们物种遗产的一部分。我们对它拥有物种垄断权。而放弃这一点在我看来非常奇怪。
We have a species monopoly, meaning other animals have not mastered fire and we have?
我们拥有物种垄断权，意思是其他动物没有掌握火而我们掌握了？
That's right. And I'm sure we will never allow any other species.
没错。而且我相信我们永远不会允许任何其他物种掌握。
I was going to say, if snakes get fire, what will we do?
我正想说，如果蛇得到了火，我们该怎么办？
I think we're in big, big trouble. I mean, our whole premise is that we control it.
我想我们会有大麻烦了。我的意思是，我们的整个前提是我们控制它。
If cows get fire--
如果牛得到了火——
Well, suddenly, the whole thing comes undone.
嗯，突然之间，一切都土崩瓦解了。
Yeah.
对。
Actually I've written a novel on this. And it was a real mess, because I'm not trained to write novels, but the premise seems to me a legitimate one to think about. I mean, maybe we've done such a bad job as a species that nature finally turns the task over to somebody else who can do it right.
其实我为此写过一部小说。那真是个烂摊子，因为我没有受过写小说的训练，但这个前提在我看来是一个值得思考的合法前提。我的意思是，也许作为一个物种我们做得太糟糕了，以至于自然最终把这项任务交给了能把它做对的人。
Stephen Pyne is the author of the books Burning Bush, Fire in America, and World Fire.
斯蒂芬·派恩是《燃烧的灌木》、《美国的火》和《世界的火》等书的作者。
Act five, The Fire Within. To be honest, this next story isn't really about fire. It's called fire. It mentions fire. The writer's name is Rennie Sparks. But basically, we just really liked this story, and we thought we would end the show with it today.
第五幕，“心中的火”。老实说，下一个故事并不是真的关于火。它叫“火”。它提到了火。作者的名字叫雷妮·斯帕克斯。但基本上，我们真的很喜欢这个故事，我们想用它来结束今天的节目。
I was car sick from reading the Sun Times in the car, but I couldn't stop reading. There was an article wedged in next to a tight column of helpful household hints, right above Today's Chuckle. The article reported a study that proved that in emergency situations, people respond more seriously when someone screamed fire than when someone screamed help. Your average person just didn't respond to the word help anymore. The word had lost its punch.
我在车里读《太阳时报》读得晕车了，但我停不下来。有一篇文章夹在一栏有用的家务小贴士旁边，就在“今日笑话”的正上方。文章报道了一项研究，证明在紧急情况下，当有人尖叫“火灾”时，人们反应比尖叫“救命”更认真。普通人对“救命”这个词不再有反应。这个词失去了冲击力。
The study coordinator suggested that people should scream fire even when there was no fire. Below that article was a piece about how putting a brick in your toilet could eventually conserve enough water to fill a kiddy pool. I stopped reading then because my husband Steven was yelling at me.
研究协调员建议人们即使没有火也应该大叫“火灾”。在那篇文章下面有一篇关于在马桶里放一块砖最终可以节约足够的淡水来填满儿童游泳池的文章。我停止了阅读，因为我丈夫史蒂文在对我大喊大叫。
He was trying to yell at me and park the car at the same time. It was too much for him. That was obvious. He was yelling things like, "You know I told you," and, "God dammit, what did I say?" You could tell he was thinking about too many things at once, and nothing was getting done right.
他试图一边对我大吼大叫一边停车。对他来说这太难了。显而易见。他在大喊诸如“你知道我告诉过你”和“该死，我说了什么？”之类的话。你可以看出他在同时思考太多事情，而没有一件事做对了。
We'd been driving around and around the cramped streets of Lincoln Park for over 40 minutes, searching for a spot. "Reading that junk is just wasting brain cells," he said. "You might as well sit an inch away from the TV." "Traffic makes me nervous, it helps if I read," I told him. "That's because you're not driving."
我们在林肯公园拥挤的街道上绕来绕去超过40分钟，寻找一个停车位。“读那些垃圾简直是在浪费脑细胞，”他说。“你还不如坐在离电视一英寸的地方。”“交通让我紧张，读点东西有帮助，”我告诉他。“那是因为你没在开车。”
We'd been going back and forth like this ever since he picked me up after work. He was mad because I hadn't asked my boss for a raise. My annual review had come and gone and I hadn't, as he put it, made my move. Steven, on the other hand, had pulled a 20% raise out of his review, plus an office with a window. A major move up, he termed it, a personal best.
自从他下班接我以来，我们就这样反复争论。他很生气，因为我没有向老板要求加薪。我的年度审查已经过去，但我没有像他所说的那样，“采取行动”。另一方面，史蒂文从审查中拿到了20%的加薪，还有一个带窗户的办公室。他说这是一个重大的进步，一个个人最佳纪录。
He was disgusted with me and the tiny cubicle in which I spent my days shuffling data, without any attempt at advancement. He'd wasted weeks before my review date, giving me pep talks to boost what he termed  my corporate competitiveness. "You either step up, Pat," he said, "or you get stepped over. It's that simple. Let them know you're on the move. Walk faster down hallways. Make quality eye contact."
他对我和我每天在那个小格子间里洗牌数据而不尝试晋升感到厌恶。在我审查日期前的几周里，他浪费了时间给我做激励谈话，以增强他所谓的我的企业竞争力。“帕特，你要么站出来，”他说，“要么被踩在脚下。就这么简单。让他们知道你正在进步。走廊里走得快点。进行高质量的眼神交流。”
Judging from the way I'd silently nodded yes, yes, yes, to every new criticism my boss had cited as reasons for giving me only a cost of living increase, I hadn't managed much of a killer instinct. My secret dream, to breed golden retrievers out on two acres in the suburbs, seemed to be moving further and further away.
从我对老板提到的拒绝给我加薪（只给了生活费调整）的每一个新批评沉默地点头是、是、是的表现来看，我没有表现出太多的杀手本能。我的秘密梦想——在郊区的两英亩土地上培育金毛猎犬——似乎正渐行渐远。
Steven turned the car into the alley behind our building. This was the sign that we were giving up our parking search for the day. He backed us in next to a dumpster surrounded by no parking signs and broken glass. We already had 15 outstanding $100 tickets from parking in this alley. 10 was the suggested limit before they towed, but Steven refused to take mass transit. He had a system. Every time he parked the car, he turned the wheels as far to the right as they'd go. He was convinced this made it impossible for the car to be towed.
史蒂文把车开进我们楼后的小巷。这是我们今天放弃寻找停车位的信号。他把车倒进一个被禁止停车标志和碎玻璃包围的垃圾箱旁边。我们已经因为在这个小巷停车收到了15张100美元的未缴罚单。10张是被拖走之前的建议限额，但史蒂文拒绝乘坐公共交通工具。他有一套系统。每次停车，他都把轮子向右打到底。他坚信这让车不可能被拖走。
Unfortunately, Steven was a man of many such theories. He insisted that light beer was 90% water, and that all TV networks were working together behind the scenes. He'd flip up and down the 10 o'clock news shows comparing anchor people, graphics, weather reports, until inevitably, he'd hit two shows doing a special report on the same subject, or two networks airing the same commercial at the same time. "See, look at this," he'd yell at the screen. "This is exactly what I'm talking about."
不幸的是，史蒂文是个有很多这种理论的人。他坚持认为淡啤酒有90%是水，所有的电视频道都在幕后合作。他会来回切换10点的新闻节目，比较主播、图形、天气预报，直到不可避免地，他会撞见两个节目在做关于同一主题的特别报道，或者两个网络同时播出同一个广告。“看，看这个，”他对着屏幕大喊。“这正是我在说的。”
Steven parked so close to the dumpster, I had to crawl over the gear shift to his side to get out. We walked quickly up the alley to the street. Just as we turned onto our block, he grabbed my arm. "Pat, have I died and gone to heaven? Am I having a stroke?" A lone station wagon with wooden siding was pulling out a few feet ahead of us inch by inch, exposing pavement as dark as new tar and a gleaming white curb. The space hadn't seen sunlight in decades. It was like seeing a new $100 bill.
史蒂文停在离垃圾箱太近的地方，我不得不爬过换挡杆到他那边才能下车。我们快步沿着小巷走到街上。就在我们转到我们那条街时，他抓住了我的手臂。“帕特，我是不是死后去了天堂？我是不是中风了？”一辆带木质镶板的单厢车正慢慢驶出，就在我们前面几英尺处，露出了像新柏油一样黑暗的路面和闪闪发光的白色路缘。这个空间几十年没见过阳光了。就像看到一张崭新的100美元钞票。
I swallowed hard, sucking my cheeks in in excitement. "Is that a spot or is that a spot?" Steven was grinning so hard his face began to leap and twitch, his fingers flexing in and out against my arm, like a cat clawing a blanket. "It's a spot, all right," I said. "A big one. You want to bet on how many seconds before it's gone?"
我努力咽了口口水，兴奋地吸着腮帮子。“那是个停车位还是个停车位？”史蒂文笑得太厉害，脸开始跳动和抽搐，手指在我手臂上抓挠，就像猫抓毯子一样。“那是个位子，没错，”我说。“一个大位子。你想打赌它会在多少秒内消失吗？”
"Listen," he said in a quick whisper. "Go stand in it while I get the car. Don't let anyone in, not anyone."
“听着，”他快速耳语道。“去站在那儿，我去把车开过来。不要让任何人进来，任何人都不行。”
"Steven, you can't save spots by standing in them," I said. "This isn't kindergarten. This is the kind of thing people get shot over."
“史蒂文，你不能靠站在那儿来预留停车位，”我说。“这不是幼儿园。这是人们会因此开枪的事情。”
"Just stand there. You've got to stand somewhere, am I right?" His voice reached a threatening pitch. Sweat was beaded up on his forehead. "Pat, get in that spot."
“你就站在那儿。你总得站在某处，对吧？”他的声音达到了威胁的高度。他额头上布满了汗珠。“帕特，站到那个位子里去。”
I stepped forward into the space, staring down at the indentations his burgundy loafers made in the strip of grass between the sidewalk and the street. I curled my hands into firsts, and pressed my fingernails into my palms so hard I snapped off a nail. I felt like sobbing. These were acrylic nails that had cost a fortune at Lovely Lady, a nail salon by the lake. I forced my fingers out straight and dropped the broken nail, a flash of fluttering pink. Steven disappeared into the alley.
我向前跨进空间，盯着他那双酒红色乐福鞋在人行道和街道之间的草地上留下的压痕。我把手握成拳头，指甲深陷进掌心，直到断了一根指甲。我感觉快要哭了。这是我在湖边一家叫“可爱女士”的美甲沙龙花了大价钱做的水晶指甲。我用力把手指伸直，丢掉了断掉的指甲，那一抹颤动的粉红色。史蒂文消失在小巷里。
A minute passed in silence. I detected the faint smell of something green lurking underneath the city air. I closed my eyes for a moment, imagining a perfect lawn, a cement patio, and golden retrievers in a wire mesh kennel.
一分钟在沉默中过去。我闻到了城市空气下隐约飘来的一丝绿色气息。我闭上眼睛片刻，想象着一个完美的草坪、水泥露台，还有铁丝网笼子里的金毛猎犬。
Headlights swept across me then, a car turning the corner, a big rumbling car, but behind the wheel, a delicate man so dwarfed by his car, I imagined him propped up on telephone books to reach the wheel. His window rolled down, his pushed his head out, carefully maneuvering a worn Cubs cap through the open window.
那时车灯扫过我，一辆车转过弯，一辆巨大的轰鸣的车，但在驾驶座后面，一个精致的男人被他的车衬托得如此矮小，我以为他是垫着电话簿才够到方向盘的。他的窗户摇了下来，他探出头，小心翼翼地把一顶破旧的小熊队球帽从打开的窗户中探出来。
He said something, but I couldn't quite catch it. His voice was high and thin, freakishly feminine.
他说了些什么，但我没完全听清。他的声音又高又细，尖锐得女性化。
I stepped forward, but still I couldn't hear what the man was saying, even though I saw his neck straining, veins bulging as he raised his voice. I just couldn't quite catch it. Or at least, I hoped I hadn't, because what I thought he said was, "Are you going to move, or do I have to run you over?"
我向前一步，但仍然听不清那个男人在说什么，尽管我看到他的脖子紧绷，青筋凸起，声音提高。我只是没能完全听清。或者至少，我希望我没听清，因为我认为他说的是：“你打算挪动，还是得我把你碾过去？”
I glanced toward the alley, no sign of Steven. The man lurched his car into park and lifted himself up so that half his torso came up out of the window. This time I heard him clearly. "Are you trying to save that spot?" He smiled at me. I looked down around me at the space and nodded. "My husband is pulling up from the alley." We both turned, staring down the alley. Nothing.
我朝小巷扫了一眼，没有史蒂文的影子。男人把车挂入停车档，把自己撑起来，半个躯干从窗户里升了出来。这次我听清了。“你是不是想预留那个位子？”他对我微笑着。我低头看看周围的空间，点了点头。“我丈夫正从小巷里开过来。”我们俩都转过身，盯着小巷那边。什么也没有。
"You think there's room for two?" The man asked. I stared across the empty space, measuring car lengths with my eyes. This was just the kind of spatial relationship task I'd done poorly at in school. "I don't know," I said, "I mean I guess." Before I could work on my reasoning, he smiled at me again. I sent him back a wide grin. He returned a soft, knowing stare.
“你觉得有空间容下两辆车吗？”男人问。我盯着空荡荡的空间，用眼睛测量车长。这正是那种我在学校里做得不好的空间关系任务。“我不知道，”我说，“我的意思是，我猜吧。”在我还没来得及思考之前，他又对我微笑了。我也回给他一个大大的笑容。他回了一个柔软、心知肚明的注视。
Just as the man pulled into the parking spot, and I saw with a jolt of fear that there was definitely not going to be room for two cars after all, our car appeared at the mouth of the alley with Steven hunched over the wheel.
就在那个男人驶入停车位，我惊恐地发现空间绝对不够容下两辆车时，我们的车出现在巷口，史蒂文蜷缩在方向盘上。
He looked at the spot being taken, looked at me, then squealed in reverse back down the alley. "Was that your husband?" The man asked. He was out of his car now. He had on a black t-shirt and shiny lycra bike pants. His arms and legs were pale and bony, and hung helplessly from his torso.
他看着位子被占用，看着我，然后尖叫着倒退回小巷里。“那是你丈夫吗？”男人问。他现在下车了。他穿着一件黑色T恤和闪亮的莱卡骑行裤。他的胳膊和腿苍白而瘦骨嶙峋，无力地挂在躯干上。
"He was here a minute ago," I said. "He backed down into the alley. I guess he thought there wasn't room."
“他刚才还在呢，”我说。“他倒回小巷里去了。我猜他认为没空间。”
"Well, what kind of car does he drive?" The man asked. "A Nissan," I told him.
“好吧，他开什么车？”男人问。“一辆尼桑，”我告诉他。
"Oh, he can fit. He can definitely fit. Go get him. I can move up further. I'm sure of it." I had my doubts, but remembering our shared smiles, I moved up onto the sidewalk and cut across to the alley.
“哦，他能挤进来。他绝对能挤进来。去叫他。我可以往前移一点。我确定。”我对此表示怀疑，但记起我们共同的微笑，我跨上人行道，横穿到小巷。
Just as I stepped away from the spot, a car turned up the block, a Cadillac. I looked back. "Go on," the man waved me forward. "I'll save the spot. Besides," he lowered his voice, "it's a Caddy. She'll never fit in a million years." I smiled. The man shot back a smirk. I headed down the alley.
就在我离开位子时，一辆凯迪拉克转弯上来了。我回过头。“去吧，”男人向我挥手。“我会保留位子的。再说，”他压低声音，“那是一辆凯迪拉克。她一百万年也不可能挤进去。”我笑了。男人回以坏笑。我朝小巷走去。
Steven was double parked next to the dumpster again. I knocked on the glass. He held his finger on the window button. The glass hummed down into the door.
史蒂文又并排停在垃圾箱旁边。我敲了敲玻璃。他把手指按在窗户按钮上。玻璃嗡嗡地缩进门里。
"I'm sorry," I told him. "I thought there was room. That guy says he'll try and move up if you want to pull in again."
“对不起，”我告诉他。“我以为有空间。那个人说如果你想再开进去，他会尽量往前移。”
"No one," Steven said, his voice arcing up towards hysteria, "on this entire planet, in any car, from any country, could fit into that spot. I'm not going to embarrass any of us by trying."
“没有人在，”史蒂文说，他的声音尖锐起来走向歇斯底里，“这个星球上的任何人，开任何国家的任何车，能挤进那个位子。我不会因为尝试去挤而让我们中任何一人丢脸。”
"Well, what do you want to do then?" I asked.
“好吧，那你想做什么？”我问。
"OK, OK." He let out a long, theatrical burst of air. "I'll go through the motions. Why not? Why don't we just sleep in the car tonight? Hook the TV to the dashboard and just wait for the police to show up in the morning." He stepped  on the clutch, the skin around his eyes and mouth quivering violently.
“好吧，好吧。”他发出一声冗长、做作的叹气。“我会走个过场。为什么不呢？我们今晚为什么不睡在车里？把电视接到仪表盘上，等着警察明天早上出现。”他踩下离合器，眼睛和嘴巴周围的皮肤剧烈地颤抖。
"Go on," I yelled, "you can do it." I turned and ran back up the street. Halfway there, Steven burst past me, motor roaring.
“去吧，”我大喊，“你能做到的。”我转身跑回街上。跑了一半，史蒂文咆哮着马达从我身边冲过。
When I turned the corner, the man was in his car, pushing it up against the bumper of the car in front of him. There was the squeal of metal rubbing against metal. The car in front moved up an inch or two, and then slammed into the back bumper of the next car up. The man turned the car off, jumped out, smiling. He'd created at most another four or five inches of space.
当我转弯时，那个人在车里，把它紧贴在前车的保险杠上。金属摩擦金属发出尖叫声。前车向前移动了一英寸或两英寸，然后撞上了前面下一辆车的后保险杠。男人关掉车，跳下车，微笑着。他最多又腾出了四五英寸的空间。
Meanwhile, Steven had pulled halfway into the spot and pulled back out again. Finally, he screeched off again down into the alley for the third time.
同时，史蒂文已经开进位子一半，然后又开了出来。最后，他第三次尖叫着开回小巷里。
The man and I stood in silence on the sidewalk as a Honda came around the corner and glided smoothly into the spot. Two girls jumped out. "Marla's apartment is that way," one of them said to the other. "She's got this new futon couch and faux marble." I caught their perfume in the air as they clicked away down the sidewalk, something between watermelon and lilies.
男人和我沉默地站在人行道上，一辆本田车转过弯，顺畅地滑进了那个位子。两个女孩跳了出来。“玛拉的公寓在那边，”其中一个对另一个说。“她有这个新家具和仿大理石装饰。”我捕捉到空气中她们留下的香水味，那是西瓜和百合之间的味道。
Steven said faux was for wimps. He liked earth tones. Everything had to be earth tones, so that our apartment ended up looking like a pile of dirt.
史蒂文说“仿造”是给懦夫用的。他喜欢大地色。所有东西都必须是大地色，所以我们的公寓最终看起来像一堆泥土。
I walked down the alley. Steven was bent over the trunk of the car, pushing down hard enough to make the car bounce. "Damn this trunk," he said. "It's never worked right since we were broken into."
我走进小巷。史蒂文正弯腰靠在车后备箱上，用力按下，使车身反弹。“该死的后备箱，”他说。“自从我们被入室抢劫以来它就从来没好用过。”
"I'm sorry I gave away our spot," I said. "I knew in a second we wouldn't fit," he snapped. "Not in a million years." He lunged one last time onto the trunk and it clicked painfully into the lock.
“对不起，我弄丢了我们的位子，”我说。“我一秒钟就知道我们挤不进去，”他厉声说。“一百万年也不可能。”他最后一次猛地扑在后备箱上，它痛苦地咔哒一声锁上了。
"I shouldn't have done it," I said. "I know that now." "It doesn't matter, Pat," he said, turning to face me, resting his weight against the car. "What's one more ticket at this point? We might as well start parking in bus stops and handicap zones."
“我不该那么做的，”我说。“我现在知道了。”“没关系，帕特，”他说，转过身面对我，体重压在车上。“此时此刻再多一张罚单算什么？我们不如开始停在公交站和残疾人专用区里。”
There were footsteps behind us. It was the man who'd taken our spot. He stood a moment, staring at us, pushing his shirt down into his bike pants. "Your car is big for a Nissan," he said finally. "Yeah," Steven said, "and heavy. Burns a lot of oil."
我们身后有脚步声。是那个抢走我们位子的人。他站了一会儿，盯着我们，把衬衫塞进他的骑行裤里。“你的车对于尼桑来说太大了，”他最终说。“是的，”史蒂文说，“而且很重。费很多油。”
"I'm sorry I took your spot," the man said. "My car is bigger than I thought. Do you live here?" He pointed to our building. We nodded. "I just moved in," he said. "Last week during the storm."
“对不起我占了你们的位子，”男人说。“我的车比我想象的大。你们住这儿吗？”他指了指我们的公寓楼。我们点了点头。“我刚搬进来，”他说。“上周风暴期间。”
We headed up the alley and around to the front courtyard, the man talking as we walked, following a step behind. "I just moved in, like I said, and already I can't take the noise."
我们沿着小巷走到前面的院子，那人一边走一边说话，跟在我们身后一步远。“我刚搬进来，像我说的，我已经受不了这噪音了。”
I held the gate open, and then the three of us were standing in the courtyard. We stopped, surrounded by our building on three sides, and behind us, the street. High above us, the third floor maybe, someone was practicing a clarinet, and in one of the open windows on the first floor I could hear a woman talking softly. "That's a good kitty. Mama loves a good baby kitty."
我打开大门，然后我们三个人站在院子里。我们停了下来，三面被公寓楼包围，身后是街道。在我们高处，也许是三楼，有人在练习单簧管，在一楼打开的窗户里，我能听到一个女人柔和地说话。“真是只乖猫。妈妈爱乖猫咪。”
"Do you have a problem with the noise?" The man asked. "Sure," Steven said, "everybody does." "Frankly," the man said, "I don't know if I can take it. The woman above me walks back and forth all night long. That's not normal in my book." "You should talk to her," I offered.
“你们有噪音问题吗？”男人问。“当然，”史蒂文说，“每个人都有。”“坦率地说，”男人说，“我不知道我能不能受得了。楼上的那个女人整夜走来走去。在我看来这不正常。”“你应该跟她谈谈，”我提议。
We were standing in a circle, but suddenly, as if he'd made a decision, the man stepped forward towards Steven, putting his back to me. He kept talking.
我们站成一个圆圈，但突然间，仿佛他做了个决定，男人向前迈向史蒂文，背对着我。他继续说话。
"I went up there twice already, and she said she's going to call the police on me. 'Fine,' I told her. It's my peace being disturbed, not hers."
“我已经上去两次了，她说她要报警抓我。‘好吧，’我告诉她。是我在被干扰，又不是她。”
"Get a broom," Steven said. "I've used a broom." "What?" The man said, stepping closer. "On the ceiling," Steven explained. "Oh, so you do have noisy neighbors," the man said, excited. "We did." Steven told him. "They were old people, banging around in wheelchairs all day, then the man died. That ended it."
“拿把扫帚，”史蒂文说。“我用了扫帚。”“什么？”男人说，走近了一步。“在天花板上，”史蒂文解释道。“哦，所以你们确实有吵闹的邻居，”男人兴奋地说。“我们曾经有，”史蒂文告诉他，“他们是老人家，整天在轮椅上砰砰作响，然后那男的死了。这就结束了。”
"You mean the woman quieted down without him?" The man asked, thrusting in front of me so I had to take a step back against the wall of the building. "Oh no," Steven said, "nothing like that."
“你是说那女的没有他之后就安静下来了？”男人问，推到我前面，所以我不得不向后退一步贴住楼墙。“哦不，”史蒂文说，“一点也没。”
"Well, like I say, I just moved in," the man said, interrupting. His voice was growing hoarse. "And I have friends on Bryer, you know, right around the corner. They have parking there, but you have to pay, and the waiting list is so long you practically have to kill someone to move up." His voice sped up. "The indoor's more expensive, but not so much, really, I mean, you have to realize outdoor is crazy. You're getting no protection at all. Zip."
“好吧，就像我说的，我刚搬进来，”男人打断说。他的声音变得嘶哑。“我有朋友住在布莱尔，你知道，就在拐角处。他们那儿有停车场，但你得付钱，排队名单太长了，你几乎得杀个人才能排到。”他的声音加快了。“室内更贵，但其实没那么多，我的意思是，你必须意识到室外很疯狂。你一点保护都没有。零。”
He caught his breath and stepped back onto my foot. I slid along the bricks, out of his way. "You know," he continued, "I don't know too many people around here, but I'm making it a point to tell everyone I meet, my friends on Bryer tell me someone was robbed at gunpoint in the lobby the other night. I mean, the only reason I'm telling you this is that they're right around the corner, and if you look, they have the same kind of lobby we do. You know, an outer door, and then mailboxes, and then a locked door. They wait for you to come get your mail. I don't want to ruin your night, but robbed at gunpoint, that's the worst, isn't it?"
他喘了口气，又踩到了我的脚上。我沿着砖墙滑走，躲开他。“你知道，”他继续说，“我在这儿认识的人不多，但我现在特地告诉每一个遇到的人，我在布莱尔的朋友告诉我，那天晚上有人在大厅持枪抢劫。我的意思是，我告诉你这个的原因是他们就在拐角处，如果你看看，他们有和我们一样的大厅。你知道，一道外门，然后是信箱，然后是一道锁着的门。他们等着你去拿信。我不想毁了你们的夜晚，但持枪抢劫，那是最糟的，不是吗？”
I looked up at the sky. A helicopter was clicking past in the darkness. It was one of those questions, would you rather be burned to death, or frozen?
我看向天空。一架直升机在黑暗中发出咔哒声飞过。这是一个问题，你宁愿被烧死，还是冻死？
"That's why I always carry $10 in my wallet," Steven said. "What do you mean?" The man asked, stepping forward now, towards Steven. "I haven't heard this one." "$10 is usually enough they won't shoot," Steven said. "They just want something." He spoke slowly, his face luminescent under the street lights.
“这就是为什么我钱包里总是放10美元，”史蒂文说。“你什么意思？”男人问，向前迈了一步，走向史蒂文。“我没听说过这个。”“10美元通常就够了，他们就不会开枪，”史蒂文说。“他们只是想要点东西。”他说话很慢，在路灯下，他的脸发出微光。
I stepped forward, trying to catch Steven's gaze over the man's shoulders. "I just read something I think you'll both find interesting," I said. My voice sounded raw and crazy. They turned. Steven's arm was blocking his chest, the man swivelling around on the point of one toe.
我向前一步，试图越过男人的肩膀捕捉史蒂文的目光。“我刚读到一些我想你们都会觉得有趣的事，”我说。我的声音听起来嘶哑而疯狂。他们转过身。史蒂文的手臂挡住他的胸口，男人绕着脚尖旋转。
"Actually, it's right along this vein of conversation," I said, pausing for breath, trying to think how Steven might tell it. "They say," I said, voice rising up high, "that is, the professionals, that when you're attacked, you should never scream, 'help,' because nobody listens. No one takes that word seriously anymore."
“实际上，这正是我们谈话的脉络，”我说，停下来喘口气，试着思考史蒂文会怎么说。“他们说，”我说，声音高涨，“也就是说，专业人士，当你受到攻击时，你不应该尖叫‘救命’，因为没人听。没人再把那个词当真了。”
"Is this a joke?" The man asked. "I don't think I've heard this one. My roommate has a book of 1,000 space shuttle jokes. I mean, get a life, right?" Steven was staring at me as if I had completely broken with reality. Gypsy moths beat their wings noisily against the shining lamps over the doorway. The clarinet player had stopped. I felt like the whole building was silent, waiting.
“这是个笑话吗？”男人问。“我觉得我没听过这个。我的室友有一本1000个航天飞机笑话的书。我的意思是，有点生活目标好吗？”史蒂文盯着我，好像我已经完全脱离了现实。吉普赛蛾在门口的亮灯上吵闹地拍打着翅膀。练习单簧管的人停下了。我感觉整个大楼都安静了，在等待着。
"They have statistics that prove this, that in an emergency," I was gasping for air now, "it seems more people listen when you scream, 'fire,' even when there is no actual fire."
“他们有统计数据证明这一点，在紧急情况下，”我现在在大口喘气，“似乎当你尖叫‘火灾’时，更多人会听，即使并没有真正的火灾。”
Steven's face was bright red, a vein pulsing in the center of his forehead. Suddenly the man spoke. "Fire?" He asked, "do I have this right?"
史蒂文的脸通红，前额中央有一根静脉在搏动。突然，男人说话了。“火灾？”他问，“我没听错吧？”
We stepped forward in unison, Steven and I, almost swallowing the man up. "Fire," we said, at precisely the same moment, with precisely the same inflection. I felt my insides leap up. Steven's eyes flashed to mine.
史蒂文和我同时向前迈了一步，几乎吞没了那个人。“火灾，”我们异口同声地说，带着完全一样的语调。我感到内心跳动。史蒂文的眼睛闪烁着看向我。
Rennie Sparks.
雷妮·斯帕克斯。
Our program today was produced by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Paul Tough, Julie Snyder, Nancy Updike, contributing editor Sarah Vowell, Jack Hitt, and Margie Rockland. Music help today from Steve Cushing. Susan Perabo's story originally appeared in TriQuarterly .
我们今天的节目由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人制作，保罗·托夫、朱莉·斯奈德、南希·厄普代克，特约编辑萨拉·沃威尔、杰克·希特和玛吉·洛克兰共同参与。今天的音乐协助来自史蒂夫·库欣。苏珊·佩拉博的故事最初发表在《三季刊》上。
If you'd like a copy of this program, call us at WBEZ in Chicago, phone number 312-832-3380, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] .
如果您想要本节目的副本，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，电话号码312-832-3380，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮箱地址，[email protected]。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金来源鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who says--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他说——
You either step up, or you get stepped over. It's that simple.
你要么站出来，要么被踩在脚下。就这么简单。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。